with a brand new upper body injury so can some
concern there but he's been hobbling a little
bit and you know he blocks a lot of shots here's
Thomson he'll put one to the net and it's saved
by Gibson looking to the front throws on the
brakes finds Horvat a shot knocked down Gibson
couldn't swallow it up but it's clear nobody in
front of the net there and that was a easy save
for Gibson Gibson's a good golender been around
a long time but he's a good goenda Henri and
short handed a slap shot caught part of the post
and sprayed out of play now bites lbushkin drops
it off a shot there finds the mid of Simeon
barl he just said everybody to ad man picked
up their game about seven eight games ago they
knew they had to be better wasn't one or two
guys it was everybody Leon for Horvat back hand
shot trying to go fle save getson rebound there
for barzel and Gibson Flags down the rebound
to he loves playing Anders Lee that is loves
playing with Horvat and and baralan and he
and he just feels so comfortable as we see
Horvat on the guys have been going down like
crazy that that was barzal went down and pal
go down and cikas going down for back to
the back post to tap right at the pan they
store Mike Riley jams it home on the second
effort his second goal and the Islanders and
it's one- nothing Well Thomas you called it
just pick up the pace a little bit find a way
to score a goal and Corbat was down there
and that was three three attempted Saves
by GI into the goal tender by his team so if
they rule that Mike Riley was knocked into
Gibson by silverberg it's a good goal
by rule after coach's challenge video
review it was determined that there
was goaler interference we have no
taken by lome uses his net as a pick hands
it off to Cam Fowler yeah game cam fower gave
him an out otherwise he was in trouble good
pressure there by fashing creates a turnover
Nelson behind the net centers it the post in in
Kyle Paul Mary what nothing Islanders yeah that
all starts with getting the puck in getting
in on the for Check Yes L had the puck but it
was fasion who read the play WI right was
able to get a good went to work waed that
opportunity look at the good good for check
right there steals the puck from lome and then
a little reverse and here comes Paul Mary
right off the bench thank you very much on
the short side as Gibson just couldn't quite
squeeze squeeze it hard enough but there not
I mean that's just good heart for checking
that's the fashion that the coach is love
hockey betting lines oh what a pass is in rink
wide feed got it right back from putter but he
scores what passing for the Islanders
in case cikis BLS it up to make it two
nothing dopper I thought he was going to go
up the Middle look at this pass all the way
across little three-way passing play cus slows
himself down clutter waits for him but Seeker
he's going to wait wait wait and then clutter
bck finds him and this is almost an empty net
goal but it all starts with a Faceoff win so czika
starts it he finishes it much tougher power play
to operate without a couple of the guns still
got Leo Carlson we talked about Frank vrono Al
scor shot there goes into the back of the net
From The Far Side it's chance for Troy Terry
that redirects in off foro and Anaheim with
the power play goal has got back to within
one yeah that's a lucky one as berzo is in good
places Terry just rifles it right across on the
ice probably a seam pass and watch the I believe
it's the left skater of number 41 and no chance
for varlamov I mean you're thinking it's going
all the way across watch this bang and then oh
you rotten son of a gun and that's just a bad
break head on for leing and then vrono vrono
to the corner is going to get wrapped up there Le
in with the front and breaking a stick on a shot
was B and N and it winds up going in a little
change up as bakan Nan had his stick give out
on him but it went straight to the net and it's
tapped in by looked like uh Adam Henri at the
doorstep puck gets in chipped in hard but trano
goes in on it protects the puck and then watch
he just chips it in behind the net and AO leaves
the front of the net and two guys going to the
same guy again you know Henri was out further and
that's where there's a little bit of a breakdown
there but that that's just a lucky goal someone
should have picked up enri taking him out of the
play that didn't happen and if someone's late
Butch and he's talk about back and n and coming
down there someone's late that's his now it's
taken out to Center by calor and he'll pass by
Carlson who exits the Box immediately but Ang
ball steals it away he's back in Dragon shoots
Gibson with the save the rebound there still
loose Anders Lee with a shot that's turned
away key injuries but all three of those guys
are on this four game Road Trip they all have
the potential to return to action this weekend
as Riley Z cross side pass the back door Holstrom
deny oh what a play that was by pasal and the only
reason he didn't score Thomas you'll understand
this he didn't stop he needed a stop in front of
the net and that was a tap in for him he just kept
going you got to stop you're right but you had
two waack out you see the advant oh one to the
front buluk with a nice play there redirected
just off the mark that was within inches foro
then and taken by Carrick he's H Dron shoots he
scores that's great I think it went off of uh of
s buluk stick there as he tried to extend out to
to block that shot Ross Johnson on the ice for
that one you'll get another look at it butch but
you tell me I think this goes off the stick and
that's why yeah this is just bounces past forzo
and little wrist shot I'm I'm not sure you might
POS I'm positive here you're going to see it hit
his stick totally change his Direction that's
three on vley tonight they go off of oh did hit a
stick no question silers hope it's less than that
as it's Paul Mary barzel doson WIS F do rather
porzel shot stopped rebounds there and swung
around as Nelson is forced to the ice Thomson with
the keep barzel takes the look Horvat barzel he
scores Matt barzel on the power play and
we're all tied at three well good job to
keep that puck in with Brock Nelson and then
doson making a quick decision he gets it right
over right away barzel practices that shot
every day he's on the ice he practices it
just before the game's going to start when they
have the warm up so good give and go and he just
wires that one so that that's not a lucky
shot by so it is a power play for the Ducks
which has the potential to bleed into overtime
hairy moments here for the Islanders yep there
you go and right away this is going to even it
up not even 10 seconds in delay penalty homr
scores wow Simon Holstrom gives the Islanders
the lead on the delayed penalty 43 Isles what
a goal from Holstrom set up in the toy
department didn't seem to have much of
an angle Paso just gives it to him and HS him
with good speed well that's not a good goal
if you're Gibson you know what else it is too
but you got Leo Carlson playing defense you're
on the power play I think a recognition from
Simon Holstrom there a little bit more space
than perhaps it defensely would give you yeah
but that's he's down there no reason to be down
I mean what look where he's letting that shot
go and he gives up that short a dozen seconds
left Fowler six on four on for strong steps
shoots BL down and hell for Lama boy how did
he see that how did he possibly see that he
totally screamed in front as Henrik was in
front and vley somehow Spears it Varley chance
breaking out here at UBS Arena a look here at
our save of the game brought to you by Volvo cars
of Beauty from siman barl now look at Henri right
in some folks standing on them face off one
by the dcks time runs out and listen to this
crowd